Hôm nay, hôm nay, tổng thống Belarus ở ngoài lần giản từ Lukashenko, người đang ở chuyến thăm chính thức đến Chủ Tien,
giao dài 2 ngày cho biết, mùa quan hệ giữa hang yếu là mức và mùa dài đoạn mới theo hạt thục tấn標 cá của Belarus,
trong cuộc khuổi đàn bởi nhà lãnh đạo Chủ Tien, khi im trang ơn, tổng thống Lukashenko cho rằng mùa quan hệ hiểu nghĩ,
hành lúc mắt mua nguồn từ thời liên sâu trước này và chưa bao giờ bị giành đoạn, hiện nay, nhờ,
quá trình phát triển tròan dịt và tiến bộ, quan hệ hành lúc đàn bước và mùa dài đoạn khoảng tấn mới,
bất chấp khoảng cách để li, về dân Belarus và Chủ Tien và tổn két như giả trí chung như lòng yêu nước và tôn trong lịch sử.
Ôu Lukashenko nhìn mạnh trong bối cảnh tình hình thề dưới biến đổi nhánh trong những hiện nay,
các cuộc gia đột lập cần tương tác trả chế hơn, tăng cường nỗ lực nhằm bảo về Chủ Tien và nân cá phúc lợi cho công dân.
Về phần mình nhé là đặc trí hoát triển kịp trận uống đuyền bố nước này, mấy tỏ xử đoạn két và uống hộ hành tỏa
Belarus, cuo gia theo đuổi chính xác độc lập phủ hộ với đất nước, đạt được phó bình và phát triển.
Đông thời tiếp tục phát triển quan hệ với các cuo gia thân thiện chuyển thống.
Theo không kìm trận uống, chủ tiến và mấy đa rút đều nỗ lực góc phần sây dựng một thay dời đa cụ,
giữa trên các quyền tác được lập và công băng. Đông thời giới chỉ lập trường tương đồng với nhiều bình đề trong trường sình nghĩ sự có thể.
Điều mặt thị dụp tục đại khả năng mở giọng hơn lưỡa, quả hệ sống phương phương phủ hợp với lệ xong của hai nước.